we we do 24 things you don't know about
i mean huss magazine did 25 but but this
is i think ours is better and uh let me
tell you putin is known to be secretive
but when we interviewed him for this he
was an open book um
for example 24 things you don't know
about waterproofing uh i'm selling the p
tape as an nft
there you go i did not know that about
it um
but when immersed in icy water my penis
gets bigger
[Applause]
i'm an optimist i look at ukraine as
half invaded
uh sometimes i think about stepping down
from leadership so i could vote more of
my time to selling stolen electrons
my favorite 80s hair band motley crew ah
you thought i'd say poison
i'm the first to admit russia has
problems for example the suicide rate of
our journalist is off the charts
uh
let's just say i don't not drink human
blood
uh i own a small hotel chain in the
united states called the trump
organization
uh two interesting things about my
tattoo it says 666 and it's not a tattoo
you